[Musique]
bonjour à vous tous pour jour marseille
ma ville de coeur
je suis ravi d'être là avec vous cet
après midi mais pour rien vous cacher
quand j'ai vu le titre de ce thé dicks
marseille je me suis dit waouh
l'anglais large donc dans une approche
un petit peu scolaire je me suis dit bon
pas et si on définir ce qu'est un
pouvoir et si on définir ce qu'est une
idée pour le pouvoir comme j'ai pas
beaucoup le temps va juste rester sur la
la cheville définition de la vigne en
fleurs qui nous explique que beaux
débuts pouvoir c'était la force d'être
plus costaud et plus gros vous taper sur
l'autre si vous le plus fort vous allez
pouvoir après les choses soient peu
complexifier avait plus de sous vous
achetez
c'est vous qui allez pouvoir aujourd'hui
on est plutôt dans vous êtes plus
informés plus connectés c'est vous qui
avez le pouvoir
donc on va regarder ça du côté du
pouvoir après je me suis dit qu'est ce
que c'est qu'une idée là on remonte un
petit peu loi parce que pour avoir une
idée il faut avoir une tete favre un
crâne faut avoir un cerveau et puis pour
un cerveau fort des cellules est en
débit lent comme ça le fil de
l'évolution on arrive à peu près là vous
voyez là le procaryotes c'est le petit
truc kitambala qui ressemble un petit
deal au flagyl est que ces petites
pattes la sas et le début donc imaginer
le temps que l'évolution à mes amis pour
arriver à l'ancêtre notre ancêtre les
premiers hominidés là on est à moins 7
- 7 millions d'années la vie ça commence
il ya trois milliards d'années ou 3.8
milliards d'années d'envoyer le temps
quand même pour fabriquer ce joli
cerveau qui est le nôtre aujourd'hui
et puis c'est passé autre chose aussi il
sait pas c'est qu'à un moment on s'est
séparés d obésité et puis tout d'un coup
nous nous étions nos ancêtres nous
étions nomades chasseurs cueilleurs donc
on se déplaçait bien beau jour on se
retrouve dans des grandes plaines avec
des grandes verbe est là qu'est ce qu'on
a fait on s'est redressée et là on a
chopé le réseau c'est tenir qu'en fait
on redresse en le coup on a permis au
tronc cérébral de voiliers beaucoup plus
d'informations ce dont notre cerveau est
en fait notre cerveau c'est quoi notre
cerveau bassin petit ordinateur bio très
performant parce que il a pas besoin de
le rebrancher tous les jours il suffit
de faire une bonne bouffe etc des
copains et hop ça se rechargent saint
pée câble avec plusieurs zones et se
servent au fait qu'est ce qu'il va faire
il va capter toutes les sensations
toutes les informations toutes les
émotions et vallées ranger soigneusement
dans des endroits bien compartimenter il
ya des informations consciente et des
informations inconsciente il va être en
permanence attentif à l'évolution de
votre environnement globalement départ
ils étaient un petit peu fait pour vous
sauver du voisin brutale ou de l'animal
qui voulez vous mettre sur son menu donc
c'est une espèce de veille permanente
qui enregistre toutes vos émotions
toutes vos réactions toutes vos
sensations et vous envoient
l'information quand vous en avez besoin
soit c'est des réflexes ou non vous
n'êtes pas conscient ce soit c'est vous
avez besoin d'une information quelle
heure est-il vous savez qu'il faut
regarder la montre ou le téléphone web
donc on a cette espèce de stockage
d'informations mais mourad sensations et
puis un beau jour on a eu une sensation
commune et ça si le début du plus grand
projet je pense que là l'humanité a
vraiment fait un tournant tout d'un coup
on a vu la photo de la maison
voilà sa polo qui part sur la lune et
puis il fait une petite photo on
l'appelait le lever de terre et là c'est
probablement la première information
globalisé c'est à dire que tous ont si
on a vu la photo de la maison puis là on
a commencé à comprendre c'est un petit
peu fini il n'y avait rien autour
comploté un petit peu comme ça dans le
cosmos et puis là on s'est surtout on a
surtout s'est surtout rendu compte que
ben on n'a plus appelé ça la terre on
appelait ça la planète on a une espèce
de conscience universelle qui est allée
de pair aussi avec les débuts de
m'appeler le web net l'internet le
digital voilà on a commencé à s'auto
connecter à prendre conscience qu'on
était unie sur une même sur un même
vaisseau à lever se taire et être
connectés et là on s'est dit en fait
aujourd'hui on à force d'être sur sept
petits vaisseaux
on est en train de on a pris conscience
qu'on abîme et le vivant on a pris
conscience qu'à force de se protéger des
aléas de la vie on est en train de
détruire tout simplement le support de
vie qui sont toutes les autres espèces
alors on a commencé à inventer ça ça
commence à monter vous ont peut-être en
entendre parler un petit peu partout ça
s'appelle le biomimétisme ou la bio
inspiration du aspirations vous vous
inspirer de la vie un bios mi6 et
biomimétisme vous incluez dans cette
inspiration la nécessité d'être durable
d'inventer des nouveaux objets des
nouveaux procédés des nouvelles
technologies qui permettent de nous
donner une vie sans abîmer la vie des
autres ou le vivant alors je sais pas si
certains d'entre vous sont familiarisés
avec cette cette approche s'est pas
encore une discipline c'est pas une
discipline parce qu'elle appelle toutes
les autres disciplines pour être dans le
biomimétisme il faut trier vous ferez
les ingénieurs les physiciens des
chimistes et biologistes tout le monde
ensemble ça qu'aujourd'hui nous rentrons
dans un monde de connaissances et de
complexité et nous ne nous en sortirons
qu en agrégeant et en croisant et en
multipliant nos connaissances alors dans
la nature on peut s'inspirer des formes
vous voyez le bec du train d'être de
l'avion le plus connu c'est le le martin
pêcheur et le train à haute vitesse
japonais de tshing en scène on peut
s'inspirer des procédés la nature et
produisent yeuse mans génial
la nature c'est tout à pression
constante température ambiante sans
aller chercher au bout du monde ces
matériaux
la nature ne crée jamais rien qui soit
un déchet c'est une invention totalement
humaine la nature crée des objets qui
sont souvent polyvalents souvent auto
réparant et lorsqu'ils ont fini leur
usage reviendra dans la grande ronde du
vivant en recyclage en économie
circulaire
voilà en fait la nature nous donne des
leçons de futurs et à leurs bois je
pense est une chose c'est que sur la
plus beaucoup le temps parce
qu'effectivement le 1
le changement climatique nous rend un
petit peu plus vigilant comme ans est
conscient je rejoins totalement monsieur
attali sur le fait de changer
radicalement et rapidement la façon dont
on apprend l'histoire deux enfants si
vous prenez un livre d'histoire vous le
pré c'est comme une éponge ya que du
sang qui sortent
ouvrez les livres d'histoire partout du
le monde sait qui a tapé sur kick a fait
la guerre à qui s'est vengé qui s'est
pas venger enfin on passe notre vie a
raconté à nos enfants notre passé avec
ses ondes les humiliations ses
frustrations ses douleurs ses aides ses
rancoeurs est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
juste remplacer nos livres d'histoire
par des livres d'espoir et donner à nos
enfants des leçons de futurs prendre le
meilleur de ce que nous savons
aujourd'hui
et justement faire ces espèces de
paquets de survie et le paquet de
créativité pour inventer un monde
meilleur et les sons dans nos vieilles
rancoeurs derrière alors si on n'a plus
beaucoup de temps on a beaucoup d espace
deux tiers de la planète c'est l'océan
c'est la mer c'est à mon très stable à
mr ya pas de guerre là vous avez cinq
individus formidable sont des cachalots
ils peuvent vivre plus de 200 ans
ils ont un cerveau comme nous ils s'en
servent aussi pour protéger leurs petits
et pour faire leur vie mais ce faisant
ils détruisent personne ne se fâche avec
personne ils font la guerre à personne
certes imanche quelques poissons mais
bon c'est la chaîne alimentaire mais se
dépasser à cause d'une idée s'est fait à
cause une nécessité de survie
et puis dans cette dans cet océan il ya
toutes les autres espèces
le sang est un milieu très stable la
terre est un milieu instable parce que
nous les hommes y avons mis un peu de
chaos
et puis eu des phénomènes géologiques
climatique
donc comme nous avions un cerveau qui
était tout le temps d'observation du
moindre changement où on accumule et
plein de choses comme ça
une petit sentiment de paranoïa de
menaces permanent alors que dans l'océan
tout est stable et donc les espèces ont
le temps de se développer
date à croître une sagesse une
compétence incroyable on commence
seulement à découvrir l'extraordinaire
intelligence prodigieuse organisation
des espèces marines et là c'est
peut-être pour nous l'occasion enfin de
passer un petit peu autre chose alors si
on résume
essayons de libérer les enseignements de
la violence et de la rancoeur de nos
enfants et si on ne pensait que
finalement nos cerveaux individuelles
qui était qui était juste fait pour nous
protéger et pour nous permettre
d'interagir et ben finalement nous
savons individuelles ont commencé à en
fabriquer un beaucoup plus grand on peut
appeler ça la conscience digital est en
fait aujourd'hui au lieu de prendre tout
simplement soin de notre vie on doit
prendre soin d'eux du vivant de la vie
et qu'un grand v puisque nous faisons
partie de cette planète et ce qui est
extraordinaire aujourd'hui c'est que
nous sommes conscients que nous pouvons
que nous avons le pouvoir de penser la
vie en conscience et en bienveillance je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]